Hugh Grant as an umaluma discuss I
actually went to see the Wonka film last
night really good film I really liked
the interpretation of it Hugh Grant
doing it amazing I thought the best
movement that someone's done in a movie
for a long time because at the end of
the day when R when R do wrote that book
I don't know if they were supposed to be
dwarfs or not but I think he referred to
them as little people but a little
person doesn't always have to be someone
with dwarfism I know there's other
people dwarfers and probably screaming
at the camera right now going we've been
robbed this is our opportunity that's
been taken away from us look you you're
better than that you're telling me the
the best thing you can do in life is be
an Umpa lumper that's that's all you got
that's not no you're more than that
you're worth way more than that why
don't you play willly Wonka don't go for
the um lumper go go for the role of wily
Wonka because there's nothing there's
nothing saying you can't